more than five million people are now
known to be infected with the corona
virus new infections are easing in
Europe and the US but experts say a
second wave is inevitable in Latin
America new cases are surging Brazil
which reported the continents first case
back in February is seeing the most new
cases on Wednesday alone the country
recorded almost 20,000 new infections if
the trend continues it's likely that
Brazil could soon have the second
highest number of cases in the world
I'm now joined by a Christian Lindt Maya
from the World Health Organization in
Geneva Christian the year w-h-o says 106
thousand new cases have been reported in
the last 24 hours the most in a single
day since the outbreak began as lockdown
restrictions are eased in many places
we're still far from out of the woods
are we indeed we are and good day to you
if we look at the global trends we do
not see a decrease we actually see a
small incline still and that shows us
that exactly as you just mentioned the
going down of figures in Central Europe
and also in some other parts of the
world is not the complete picture it's
not that if we turn off like turning off
a faucet and then some [ __ ] no more
drops of cases anymore the case is
continuing actually we will see more
cases in many other countries who have
been only starting to be hit by the
virus now and who may have a weaker
health system especially the cases in
Brazil also show us that it is important
to have an all society approach to to
fighting the corona virus to fight in
the kumite outbreak because this way you
need to include instead of polarizing
you need to include everything from the
health system to the people to the the
economy only then can you win this fight
okay so you just mentioned Brazil the
situation there seems to be worse than
significantly where else do you expect
such as collisions well unfortunately we
have first of all to see that country's
little or middle-income country is also
in Africa and may certainly be a
problematic case soon
so also the rest of Latin America
because these countries only started to
see cases now and remember we were
talking about a window of opportunity
for about two months that we can prepare
these countries and these countries can
prepare themselves we can help them to
equip to get the tests ready to get the
hospitals ready to get everything ready
what they need a lot has been 30
countries have received US receives
assistance from the World Health
Organization but they will still seem to
be receiving cases and of course another
reason for increase in cases will be
that countries as they start easing the
lockdown people will start mixing again
mood on holidays will start yeah being
in contact again and so we should expect
arising cases again the European the
European Union's virus response chief
says Europe has to prepare for a second
wave when does the whu-oh expect that in
Europe I don't think we can call it a
one wave will be should not look for one
wave what this wave means it's an uptick
or less another rise and relapse in
cases after we have been seeing drops in
cases after the daily increases have
gone down with all the easing of
measures now and the communicating and
physically increasing the physical
context of people again we will see a
rise in cases again and this is the the
second wave everybody is talking about
they may not all be at the same time
this may be very different from country
to country or from region to region but
rise a secondary or third third rise in
cases is very likely it's an admirer for
w-h-o in Geneva thank you thank you now
time for some of the other coronavirus
developments the Chinese city of Wuhan
the epicenter of the outbreak has issued
a total ban on hunting breeding and
eating wild animals research suggests
the virus most likely spread from wild
animals to humans through such practices
a top US scientists has said people
should not count on a vaccine being a
developed soon William Hazeltine said
the best approach was to manage the
virus through contact tracing and strict
isolation measures when it's
start spreading Iran's deputy health
minister says some 10,000 health workers
have been infected with the virus and a
meat processing plant in the Netherlands
has been closed after some 45 employees
taste tested positive for the covert 19
virus it's the largest latest in a
number of large outbreaks in
slaughterhouses Turkey's economy was
facing hard times well before the
pandemic now it's in crisis mode
business has plummeted and the value of
the national national currency the lira
has fallen much of turkey's debt is in
foreign currency and that means it's
getting a lot more expensive to pay down
hotel owner Devesh and on whoosh now has
to drink his tea alone the once bustling
streets in Istanbul world famous Hilton
Ahmed neighborhood are empty
shondo muchos hotel has been closed
since mid-march tourism season here
kicks off in March and then we usually
have some very busy months until
November but so far we were only able to
make 10% of our yearly earnings if it
goes on like this we'll have a loss of
90 percent and it's not just the
hospitality business government revenues
are also taking a hit due to the lack of
tourists Turkey's government will need
to service an external debt of some
hundred and seventy billion dollars by
the end of the year the Turkish lira has
now tambul de round fifteen percent
against the US dollar since the
beginning of the year in this time of
crisis and uncertainty a lot of
investors are opting for much safer
currencies which is obviously the US
dollar at the moment so that's one a
channel through which the the lira has
lost value against the dollar the second
one however is Turkey's own its own
macroeconomic vulnerabilities and Turkey
got caught up in this crisis at a very
fragile state already with a weak
currency since August 2018 meanwhile
Turkey's president red chip type ido1
has blamed the liras plunge on foreign
banks and is calling on citizens to the
nave to those in need
during the pandemic
little comfort for those who've lost
their jobs the cost of living is rising
kissing Nikolas my weekly shopping was
less than 150 now I need 300 lira and
it's still not enough
everything is so expensive quality okay
they suffered a lot my company didn't
support us the state isn't protecting us
no one is helping hotel owner
Debbie Shonda moosh doesn't know what
will happen next and he has bills and
debts to pay and no incoming revenue
it's a bleak forecast ahead of what
would have been a profitable summer
season